hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
i'm a property investor and this week
on this video i'm going to be answering
your
property investment questions so
comment your questions below i've been
investing in property now for over 12
years
i've done over 300 property deals
and right now i'm going to be answering
your questions so anything property
related comment it below in the comments
i'll do my best to answer also if you
appreciate my youtube channel
please give me a massive favor smash the
like button subscribe
turn the notification bell on and let's
get started so
we got big boss big boss 619190 says i
bought a house on a buy to let mortgage
can i still refurbish then pull the
money out
okay couple things going on here big
boss number one is
does do the figures even work so taking
aside the fact
that you've got a buy to let mortgage on
it you bought it for a certain amount
that's the purchase price
the refurb is going to be a certain
amount and then there's going to be an m
value the new gdv gross development
value
do those figures stack as a deal on
in and of itself taking aside the fact
that you bought it on a buy to let
mortgage
if the figures don't stack then the
answer is no if the figures do
stack namely that the new gdv
gross development value once you've done
the refurb is
you've pushed the price up so the new
value times
0.75 because you're going to get a new
mortgage at 75
loan to value is equal to or greater
than the purchase price
plus the refurb and it stacks
that's really good if it stacks question
is you bought it on a buy to let
mortgage
what are you going to do the answer is
you could speak to your mortgage company
and see if you can get a
an extended mortgage with them a
refinance or
you could just accept that you're
probably going to have a early penalty
repayment charge depending on how long
they're fixed i assume you bought the
house
recently in which case normally you'll
be in like a two-year fixed rate
and if you refinance it before that time
of another lender they're going to
charge you might be a couple thousand
pounds depending on what you agreed
so those are the things to think about
anyone that's watching this is thinking
what is he talking about this is just
the strategy by refurbished refinance
rent
you'll get there i promise um it's not
too difficult i failed in school and now
i'm making
millions of pounds in property because i
learned the basic formulas which you're
gonna learn
on my youtube channel if you enjoy the
channel smash the like button what else
we got
ben ogden hi samuel i was on your
property investors crash course the
other week and
already booked on the next one as i
could only stay for half
fair enough get back on there it's free
question for you when getting rent to
rent is there any issues with article
four areas as it's theoretically hmo
yeah if you're getting a hmo in an
article four area
and you're trying to on a rent to rent
if it's not an existing hmo
you're gonna need planning permission
it's not really gonna work as a rent to
rent
so if you're in an article four area you
need to find existing
hmos where the landlord is tired and
then give them a guaranteed rent and
make your profit that way
um hope that helps anthony stevens
hi samuel what's your thoughts on
letting my house to the council from
what i can gather the rent is guaranteed
and the council are liable for any
damage the tenants do interest in your
thoughts and if you've done it
anthony yes i've done it it's been very
successful
and i'd recommend it as a strategy just
make sure that you get a good contract
in place so you you know you agree on
some good terms with the council or the
housing association
for sure but yeah it's good abdullah
how do you make sure when you're co-deal
sourcing that the person who sells it
for you doesn't keep all the money
contracts contracts contracts and also
good trust goodwill relationships
if you code your source in if someone
comes to you
um or if you approach a deal source and
say hey guy deal
you know you could ask them to pay you
upfront or
you could just have an agreement in
place even if it's not a proper
solicitor drawn up contract
even if it's just an email thread
confirming what's what
if they emailed it to you and it was in
black and white typed form even if it
was in plain english not solicitor
jargon
it is legally binding people forget this
people think that you need
solicitors to drop contracts for
absolutely everything they don't
you know i've been to court many times
i've been to court with my tenants i've
been to court
um i say many times as a business person
by the way
you know if you've got a lot of houses a
lot of tenants and you've been in the
game a long time at some point you're
going to have to get
you know you're going to get contracts
challenged and it's amazing because
you know it does stand up in court just
an email thread it does stand up so
hope that helps get it in writing get an
agreement
and um yeah and also if you're dealing
with a deal saucer they're not going to
screw you over for a couple grand
because they've got a reputation to
uphold as well so
all right next callum gallagher great to
have you in the comment section buddy
hope you're well he says
what would you say the best strategy is
for 2021
and why oh that's the golden question
what is the best strategy in 2021 and
why
listen i don't think there's a best
strategy
because here's you right here here's
where you want to get to
the property investment strategies are
going to depend on where you are where
you want to get to
you know maybe you're here you want to
get here maybe you're here you want to
get here so the strategies are going to
be different to get where you want to
get to
however 2021 i'm
loving the brr strategy right now
because buying a house adding value
pulling the money out refinancing it so
many of my students are doing these
deals successfully
i've had many myself that and you can do
on a small scale or a big scale
and if you know how to do it but you
haven't got the money
you can joint venture on it or you can
just package it and sell it deal
sourcing
joint venturing brr is popping 2021.
house prices are booming like crazy this
strategy is a good one so
that's probably my favorite strategy for
2021. safe
as long as you do a best case worst case
like the case you might end up leaving a
little bit of money in
it's a great great strategy okay ben
mia says hi samuel if you want to go
into service accommodation and see
operators who wants to sell their
existing service accommodation
and me taking over what diligence should
i take what figures
to look at for an estimate as a new
operator um
okay i think you're talking about i
don't know if you uh
which operators don't want to sell i'm
not quite sure i understand the question
if
i answer it wrong just comment again and
make it maybe uh clearer
but i think you're talking about
checking the demand for a service
accommodation property in which case if
that is what you're talking about
i would go on airbnb i would find a like
for like
property and you can literally see how
full
their calendar is how much they're
charging
how booked up they are i should give you
a real strong indicator
also you can go on booking.com you can
see what the prices are of other hotels
you can you can go into hotels and see
how booked up they are
serviced accommodation market right now
is not dead tourism is dead
you can get contractors relocators
business people like it is still active
and open
but tourism is dead so um
yeah hope that helps alex ives
hi samuel i've been following the
channel for ages i came on the crash
course in the beginning of last year
i'm planning on doing rent to rent
accelerator course and i've just saved
the money up for it however i'm aware
that acquiring a rent to rent deal also
requires the funds to set it up which
can be in the region of three to four
thousand pounds and i've not yet got
that saved
should i do the rent to rent accelerator
anyway or wait until i've got enough
money to do my first
deal thanks alex personally i would do
it
one billion percent and i'll tell you
why two reasons number one is
because even if you haven't got the
money when you get all the knowledge and
you know how to find the deals and i
know the program is like a four week
course anyway
um the money will come and even if
you're learning while saving that's not
a bad thing
but more importantly than that is if you
start finding deals but you haven't got
the money yourself
you can joint venture with someone you
can say hey look you put the three grand
in
i'll find the deal and do everything
else and we'll split the profits 50 50
until i've paid you back your three
grand
and some and work something out so the
person that can find the deals is the
person that wins so i would be
definitely doing it but of course it's
your decision
but either way i wish you all the very
very best and if i can help anymore
give me a shout all right um km
says if you had to start getting
property with no money but you still had
all your knowledge on property how long
do you think it would take
for you to make a million pounds in cash
a million pounds in cash
i reckon i could be a property
millionaire definitely within 12 months
a million pounds in cash do i have my
uh reputation and my contacts if so i
reckon i could do that in the year two
if i'm starting again from scratch i
don't know maybe a couple years
i'm not really sure but it would
definitely happen because my thermostat
is set for a million
and just like the thermostat in a room
this room is set for 22 degrees
so it's going to be about 22 degrees the
window might open it might be 19 for a
bit
might be a lot of people in the room
might be 24 for a bit but it's going to
get back to 22 degrees
and in the same way i'm a
multi-millionaire and
no matter what happens that's going to
always be the case i might lose it for a
while
but i'll make it back like the opposite
of someone that wins the lottery
a lottery winner the thermostat set for
low they win the lottery well but then
they lose the money
for someone that's wealthy and is
self-taught and understands how to
do what you need to do um and by the way
i say self-taught believe me i've had a
lot of mentors and trainers and people
that have helped me get to where i'm at
but ultimately
the best way to learn is by is by doing
you know if by doing
my training programs guess what i guess
what i get you doing
doing it i'll be teaching you i'll be
showing you and you'll be doing it
during the training so
um yeah man it might take me a year or
two i don't know but
how the question is how long will it
take you you know how long is it going
to take you
um i'm sure we'll find out george lao
thank you for answering my question sam
i've already taken onboard your advice
and invested myself
in the deal selling masterclass and
samuel 365. smart move george respect
keep me posted how it gets done
sammy i'm 17 i'm aiming to start rental
rent deals this year as a 17 year old do
you think i can start rent
rent deals or would i just get rejected
you're going to get rejected whether
you're 17 or 27
i get rejected all the time you're
trying to rent to rent deals you're
gonna have agents and landlords saying
no no no no no
this is what success looks like no no no
no no
oh yes i'm here like you're gonna get
rejected are you gonna get rejected
worse because you're 17
maybe although you could maybe flip the
cards maybe you could flip the cards
like i started when i was 17 i flip the
cards i use it to my advantage because
actually people want to help you when
you're 17. so if you say
look i'm i'm 17 as long as you propose
things
whereby there's not risk for them you
know i used to work for people for free
as a uh finding them tenants hey can i
find you a tenant
i won't charge you any money for it i'll
charge an admin fee to the tenant but i
just want to get experience and i want
to build relationships
that's how i started 17 they're like
yeah sure charged a little admin fee 90
pounds for the tenants
making a little bit of money was
learning but then i built relationships
with agents so that they uh
landlord so they got to know me and then
the tired ones i'm like
making them offers now they know me so
yeah you can definitely get started at
17.
it's going to be harder in some ways
easier in some ways but ultimately
you've always got to flip the cards and
use it to your advantage
adele smith what if you don't have good
credit if you don't have good credit
maybe you need to find someone that
doesn't joint venture with them
maybe you need to do a strategy where it
doesn't matter there's always a solution
you need to focus on the solution rather
than the problem
i don't have a question i just want to
say you've helped me so much in
understanding property investment i
don't know how people hate on you
i started working so i can start rent to
rent i will soon have some savings in my
account
and i will be a winner on a wednesday
keep up the good work hey
i can't wait to see you on windows on a
wednesday you know every single week
every single week on youtube i interview
one of my success students on samuel 365
or on the academy someone's doing
training with me
and um they share their story of how
they've become financially independent
through my training
via property and you know look if you
wanna if you wanna
learn more about getting coached getting
training i'll leave a link in the
description you can come to the crash
course which is free
you can do the samuel 365 which is a
pound for seven days
and it's 95 pounds a month where you
receive unlimited
one-on-one mentoring and training with
myself and my team we have weekly
coaching calls i'm not going to go on
about it just check it in
the link do me a massive favor smash the
like button
drop a nice comment subscribe turn the
bell on how disappointing would it be
if i answer your video comment below but
you don't see it because you weren't
subscribed that'll be that'll be
hard soul destroying so subscribe i'll
see you next time
you